secretary of state there is a new
assembly in northern ireland but little
prospect it seems of a new government so
how do you envisage this place being
governed in the throes of a cost of
living crisis
well first of all david i think all of
us want to see storm up and running i
think it goes without saying as i said
yesterday i think the people of northern
who voted want their politicians to take
part in the democracy that they voted in
so i'll be encouraging the party leaders
when we meet with them tomorrow as i
have done over the last few weeks and
indeed in the contact i've had with them
over the last few days to to get those
nominations in let's get the assembly
speaker elected and get the assembly up
and running there's a lot of decisions
to make for the benefit of people in
northern ireland there's money uk
governments put into the northern
executive we want to spend in northern
ireland and that means we need to get
those positions filled as quickly as
possible
but the democratic unionists have made
it abundantly clear that they've no
intention of restoring power sharing
until the government addresses their
concerns over the northern ireland
protocol that a controversial border in
the irish sea are you going to do that
in the queen's speech on tuesday
well i recognise the challenges with the
northern protocol for people across
unionism and actually the protocol is
causing problems for people across
northern ireland it's not just about
unionist parties or any one party
certainly affects communities across
northern ireland and businesses as well
regardless of their voting intentions
and we need to get that resolved it is
really frustrating that the eu have not
shown the flexibility we need to see to
get that resolution it's more
frustrating i have to say to hear over
the last couple of days that the eu seem
to be saying they're not willing to show
any any any sort of flexibility that we
need to get this resolved
we do think the right resolution is an
agreement with the eu we've always been
focused on that that's why we've not
triggered article 16 yet but we've got
to be clear you know the protocol that
was designed to protect the good friday
agreement is what is actually putting
the most stress on it at the moment we
can't let that continue we do need to
get a resolution to this we've always
said we take nothing off the table and
that hasn't changed we will do what we
need to do to resolve these issues for
the benefit of people in northern
ireland
you say you take nothing off the table
that obviously includes the possibility
of unilateral action but the prime
minister told the dup there would never
be a border in the irish sea when he
conceded on that you tried to pretend
there wasn't a border in the rsc now
you're saying the government's going to
address concerns over the border in the
irish sea so why would the democratic
unionists believe this government
well if you look back at the beginning
of this uh when i made the point about
we don't want to see them we didn't
think there'd be a border in the irc
that one of the issues was actually
about the implementation the protocol
the eu's uh way and style of wanting to
implement some of these things that we
had grace periods put in place
specifically to allow these issues to be
worked out they've never shown the
flexibility to properly resolve in the
way that we always i have today thought
that they would and the reality is this
is causing problems our job as a
government is to recognize that and to
want to deal with it it's causing
problems at a number of levels there are
communities who can't access goods and
products in the way they need to there's
businesses who are affected in the same
way that affects the whole of the uk
businesses in all the night who can't
get supplies businesses in great britain
who are not supplying northern that
affects everybody and obviously having
that pressure on east west that pressure
on stormon and the fact that stormland
isn't sitting is putting that pressure
and damage on the good friday agreement
itself we've always been very clear our
priority is and will always be the
protection of the good friday agreement
and that's why it's important we do
resolve these issues and we need to do
that
with all of the focus on the concerns of
the democratic unionist party it
sometimes creates the impression that
most people in northern ireland have
concerns about the brexit border in the
irish sea but that's not the reality of
course of the 90 people
elected to the new northern ireland
assembly 54 of them are in favor of the
protocol being implemented perhaps with
some adjustments so why is the
government really only interested in
dancing to the dups tune
well i think that's a bit of a
a misnomer that's out there i've got to
say and you've just said david actually
all of the parties now recognize and are
open with people about the fact there
are problems with the protocol i accept
they have different views about how
extreme those issues are but all the
parties want to see issues with the
protocol resolved they accept there are
problems there
pretty much every sector of the business
community almost all but one have been
very clear with us and with the eu and
others that the protocol doesn't work
the eu's offer of september last year
doesn't work they've got frustration i
think with the eu not properly engaging
with the kind of flexibilities that
would resolve these issues as we do so
it is clear that this is an issue that
affects everybody in northern ireland
and our job as uk government is to make
sure that we rectify that we want to do
that with the eu that's why our focus
has been on that rather than triggering
article 16 which we could have done last
year but there is a point at which we
will need to make some decisions around
if the eu is refusing to show
flexibility what can we do to alleviate
these issues for the benefit of citizens
of the united kingdom the people of all
communities in northern ireland
finally and very briefly there's a
nationalist first minister in scotland
there now is a nationalist first
minister elect in northern ireland is
this historic vote not proof positive
that brexit has threatened the future of
the union and could lead to the breakup
of the united kingdom
i think if we look at the facts of
what's happened over the last couple
days no doubt this is a significant
election particularly for northern
ireland because we do have a nationalist
uh elect first minister
but we also have to remember obviously
the shin of fame vote hasn't
changed their number of seats they've
went in with 27 seats they've still got
27 seats the overall vote
is very clearly there for uh for
unionism as a block it still is the
largest group uh stormont and and and
the voting on that pattern hasn't really
changed what has also been significant i
think as the person who's on the show
just before me is outlined there's been
that increase in vote and the increase
in seats that we've seen for the
alliance so i think this has been a
significant election but we also need to
be very clear i think the people in
northern their main focus what they'll
expect all of us as elected politicians
to do is get on with dealing with those
issues that affect them every day they
want to see the health service reforms
and investments in northern ireland
we've put the support in there for as uk
government they want to see the economy
growing as we recover from covid and yes
they want us to resolve those protocol
issues that i think is where the focus
for all of us needs to be in the period
ahead